e
to open the regular irregular meeting of
the joint performance audit um and
oversight Comm committee for March 18th
does anybody who's here have a time
limit on when they have to leave which
might make
us move the agenda
around oh
well if we are not finished by
12:30 um we're all going out for
lunch okay so then we will just go
through our agenda Adam chair I move to
adopt the minutes of August 11th is
there a second second seconded by
Senator jro is there any discussion on
the
minutes can we take a Voice
vote where is
Jay can we take a voice phone
okay okay
good
so if you're in favor of adopting the
minutes of August 11th please raise your
hand and re for you abstaining okay
great minut are
adopted thank you so now we're going to
turn to the status of ongoing
performance audits we'll start with
mental health Workforce licensing good
morning good morning Madam chair and
members of the committee for the record
I'm Christine Young director of audits
for the LBA and with me is Jay Henry the
performance audit
supervisor so we'd like to provide an
update of the ongoing in the pending
performance audits it's been a while
since we last met so uh I will start
with the mental health Workforce
licensing the audit is complete and the
report was presented to the fiscal
Committee in
October moving on to the special
education dispute resolution
processes that audit is also complete
and the report was presented to the
fiscal committee last
Friday New Hampshire commission for
human rights we are near the end of the
audit
we've drafted over 20 observations and
we expect to provide a draft report to
the Commission in the next few
weeks regarding the state oversight of
special education the audit is currently
staffed with four performance
Auditors we estimate that we're
approximately half
audit uh this is a very large audit
scope with numerous federal and state
laws uh expecting a lengthy Report with
40 plus
observations we don't anticipate having
a completed draft report until the end
of the
year moving on to the Secretary of
State's archives and Records uh this
committee approved the audit of the
archives at its last meeting in August
the fiscal committee approved the topic
at their September meeting
we reached out to the Secretary of
State's office in preparation for the
upcoming audit and uh it was secretary
scanland position that the archives may
not be subject to a performance
audit uh he has asked the Attorney
General's office to review whether or
not a performance audit can be
performed and we have not received any
further information on this so we are
unable to move forward with the audit
until we have a resol solution to this
matter and uh I believe there are
representatives from the Attorney
General's office here and I believe
secretary scanlin is there in the back
as well if you would like to hear from
from either of them well I think we'd
probably like to hear from both of them
okay so let's start with the Secretary
of
State
yes do you okay what
just remind me okay good morning Mr
secretary thank MERS
of I am here today because there is a
provision Dave can you turn your mic on
yeah yeah I there is a statutory
provision uh that exists in rsa1 14
colon
31a and it
uh says I'm just find it
here I always have trouble finding on a
quick glance that's what computer far
any anyway just to paraphrase it it says
that that the Constitutional officer in
the conduct of your constitutional
responsibilities are exempt from uh the
requirement of having
a performance
audit and then if you look in the
Constitution I believe it's article
67 part
two uh it clearly lists the Secretary of
State and the treasures constitutional
officers and then the next article
68 uh says that the records of the state
shall be kept in the office of the
secretary so clearly that's a
constitutional respons
ibility
and if there's a question about the
Secretary of State uh being a
constitutional officer and keeping the
records of the state as a constitutional
Duty uh I don't know how it gets any
more basic than that uh um in terms of
being a constitutional officer and
having that
responsibility so I I'd like to start my
additional comments just by saying that
I want to talk about the office first
not about me
specifically but I am not aware that
there has ever been a performance audit
of the Secretary of State's office
because when the legislature in joint
convention elects the Secretary of State
they assume individually and solely the
responsibility that is provided in the
Constitution and an oath is is sworn to
protect that uh you know that
responsibility and to do it to the best
of their ability I may only be here two
years somebody comes in and succeeds me
then uh they assume that responsibility
the management style may be different
from one person holding that office to
the next and I'm not going to be the one
that relinquishes that Authority and
seeds it to uh you the review of other
individuals that may or may not share
the same
uh requirements that I have and how that
job should be
done
um so so that's number one and number
two is from a personal perspective I
take that role very
seriously and and I am accountable uh to
the legislature because uh in joint
convention you placed me in this
position and I'm also accountable to the
people of the State of New Hampshire and
I have uh you know taken on the duty to
meet that
responsibility in a fair and impartial
way the concern that I have is that if
you start
allowing uh review of
performance uh that can be come very
public uh
and and reflects the views of other
individuals that do not have that
responsibility for records and
archives there is nothing to prevent a
performance audit then of the election
process and I have a major concern with
that because politics can come into play
and uh you know depending on which part
is in power uh you know things could
take a sharp turn in a bad Direction and
there could be undue influence through
this process placed on the individual
that
is responsible for uh making sure that
the elections in this state are fair and
impartial and I think that's one of the
reasons why this provision in the
Constitution and in the statute
exists the records and elections in my
opinion have the same weight of
responsibility in this process if you
allow a performance audit for one then
you're opening it up to the other and I
think that is very
appropriate
um I had the benefit of coming in to the
position of having served under
secretary Garder for 20 years and so
when I assumed the role I knew where the
areas were in the office that needed to
be
addressed and we've been very aggressive
uh addressing uh the issues that I have
seen uh not only in archives but AC
across the board and all of the
divisions within our
department uh if you have had the
opportunity to visit the archives
recently uh I would hope that you would
notice that the Clutter and the and the
appearance of disorganization is gone uh
that everything is in its place uh we
have hired a new uh uh archist State
archist who is Young professional and
highly trained in the issues related to
AR iives and through that we are uh
creating a new uh um inventory database
uh that's being
upgraded uh and uh you the records
classification being improved and uh
security measures are being taken both
in terms of uh keeping track of who's
entering the building and leaving uh
um uh to making sure that important
documents are being preserved properly
and I would assume that when I'm no
longer doing this job that the person
that comes in after me is going to take
an assessment of uh you know the status
of things and then put their own stamp
on what's important and move forward uh
I have no problem being transparent so
there's any member of this committee me
any member of the legislature and even
the general public that wants to come
out see how things are being run and
handled we're more than happy to uh
exercise uh that right but at this point
I think it is important that you allow
the Constitutional officer that has the
responsibility to exercise it without uh
uh undo outside influences that may or
may not be helpful I'd be happy to
answer any questions questions R
peber thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um I think
your points are are very well taken all
of them I guess my question is and you
started to answer it at the end there if
the legislature has the responsibility
for the
oversight but we are not allowed to use
the tool that we use
for many other uses and I I your point
about the elections is very well taken I
guess my question is how do
we
um exercise that Duty in a most
professional way given the um volunteer
legis volunteer nature of our
legislature so the Constitution does not
give the oversight to the legislature it
gives that responsibility to the
Secretary of
State there are laws that are passed to
develop the procedures that we can
follow uh at The Archives and we bring
those for forward when we see needs
there
the the legislature controls the pur
strings uh they create the budget that
allows the Constitutional office to
operate and we are subject to financial
audits uh I have no problem with that if
if if the legislature wants a financial
audit tomorrow or this afternoon uh then
I would say we're ready for you uh and I
will say that when I came on uh there
was a recently included Financial audit
uh of the Secretary of State's office uh
at least certain portions of it uh there
were some uh observations uh that needed
to be addressed and I can tell you that
I believe that we have addressed every
single one of those items that was
outstanding from that audit uh we have
brought in I I have brought in Personnel
to help with that um through my deputies
I I brought in Aaron Hennessy uh and uh
Patty Lovejoy I think most of you know
both of them they both have CPA
backgrounds and have been a tremendous
help in organizing the recordkeeping and
and the and the financial practices uh
in the department that were uh you know
concerns and the observations in that
report so uh we made a point to follow
through on uh on that um again it's just
an example that you know we're taking
the role the Constitutional role uh very
very seriously Senator Lane thank you so
I just want to kind of summarize we kind
of talked about a lot of stuff there so
your the the the thrust of the argument
is that under the Constitution part 268
which defines the duties of the
Secretary of State it specifically says
the records of the state shall be kept
in the office of the secretary so that's
your duty constitutional Duty as a
constitutional officer and the the
second half of that is under uh
1431 which is um the audit division the
audit division shall and under Section D
there's one particular line in the
middle of a paragraph that probably
could easily be overlooked it says this
officer shall this paragraph shall not
apply to the Constitutional officers in
the execution of their constitutional
duties that's correct and that's the
line that I was looking for at the very
beginning and that's in section D so the
argument is that it's obviously a
clearly defined duty of yours and the
audit division statute that we have
explicitly exempts constitutional
officers in the performance of their
duties from performance audits yes okay
thank you so I have a question though
and there are some duties and really I'm
thinking of Vital Records which the
legislature gave to you in 1991 when it
transferred that division over from
Health and Human Services so that's not
really a constitutional obligation it
was a
legislative requirement that the
Secretary of State took it over so the
Constitution didn't give you Vital
Records the legislature
did first of all vital records are
records of the state and and I will tell
you a
story about when Bill Gardner was
Secretary of State the records of the
state were not kept in his office they
were kept in a one of the divisions of
administrative services and there was
some issue about the records and how
they were being managed and uh and it
ended up as a court case and David suder
was the
judge uh and as the as the case was
being resolved Justice sudor said to
Bill Gardner you know the Constitution
says that you are responsible for those
records it doesn't matter that you don't
have physical control of them ultimately
you are the one that is responsible for
them and it was after that point then
that the archives was created uh under
the Secretary of State's office uh and
the records of the state are now uh kept
there so with if we had not moved vital
records from Health and Human Service
if it was still there and the legis and
this committee wanted to do a
performance audit of Vital Records
contained in Health and Human Services
would you have the same
objection that we could not do a
performance audit of them because they
were records of the state even though
you didn't have the budget you didn't
have
the legislative authority to management
you didn't have any
control over those records before they
were brought in would we hear the
same I think you might you might hear
the same argument so you might ask then
you know well is there any division in
the Secretary of State's office that is
subject to uh a performance audit and
you know clearly I think Securities
regulation would be a an example of one
of our divisions that might be subject
to a performance audit uh you know
corporations keeps State records
relative to all the business entities
that operate in New Hampshire Vital
Records is you know our role in that is
keeping the vital statistic records of
the citizens of the State of New
Hampshire and then uh we keep those
records now the information from those
records is shared with uh Health and
Human Services uh through an agreement
and through a legislative directive and
those procedures are probably subject to
uh a performance audit but the actual
keeping of the records uh uh is probably
a constitutional responsibility
so I probably wasn't clear prior to 19
I'm sorry 2001
when we moved Vital
Records would there have been a problem
with us doing a performance audit of
Vital Records when it was still over at
Health and Human
Services or was it the
moving of
that body of Records to your
office that's a good question and I I I
just don't know the answer to that yeah
Senator Lang so again as I'm listening
to that discussion the followup I would
have is again I think the Justice suit's
point there are State records that were
distributed amongst other agencies that
ultimately Justice sudor said are still
your responsibility and still your
obligation so the question that the
legislature in 2000 whatever it was
realized that these are State records
that were not not under the control of
the Secretary of State and mve them
under the control of the Secretary of
State I think it's probably the point
but I wasn't around back then when that
happened but I think that was probably
again to Justice suit point there are a
lot of Records within the state that
sometimes we have to make sure we get
control of that um so I don't know if
that's an answer other than to say I
would if it's argued that it is a state
record then it is his responsibility
therefore would not be subject to if
it's if you qualify it as a state record
if if I can just add this to for the
benefit of the committee is that the
agencies are constantly creating records
and and and in the process of doing that
they're they're following the statutes
that apply to them and I think in that
process um certainly is auditable and
then there is a period of time when the
agency records are no longer needed kind
of on a day-to-day basis but they need
to be kept for a period of time at that
point they get transferred to the
archives and then the archives holds
those
records uh and gives them back to the
agencies as needed if a court case comes
up and they need to reference those
materials or
whatever and then there is a point uh
that is established by the agency of
when those records can be destroyed and
the archives does take care of that
process once the agency signs off on
them and says so there there is a
transition of what happens with records
uh when other agencies are performing
their
responsibilities and then those records
get transferred to the
archives uh for
proper keeping and many of the records
are permanent U that's why we have to
keep adding additions onto the back of
the building to store all of those
records but
um representative
Webber I think my question's been taken
care of thank you madam chair thank
you representative
W I move that we remove this from the
list of performance audit second
suggestions any further discussion
Senator with me I think before we take
that vote we were going to hear from the
attorney general hear from the AG's
office if you
would withdraw motion I'll withdraw the
motion till we hear from
the
morning morning thank you for the record
Chris Bond associate attorney
general uh so yeah our office was asked
by the Secretary of State's office to
take a look at this
um we certainly appreciate the uh the
important oversight function that the
LBA provides but we also it's important
for us to make sure that we give meaning
to every statutory enactment and really
what we grappled with was RSA
1431 excuse me
1431a Roman 1 upset D that uh Senator
Lang just quoted from um that this
paragraph shall not apply to
constitutional officers in the execution
of their constitutional
duties um and as also noted by secretary
scanland the the Constitution does
provide that keeping of Records is a
constitutional function that the that
the secretary does so um I I appreciate
the discussion that you just had and
Senator Rosenwald you're hypothetical
about if the documents had been left uh
with vital records for example had been
left I um I'm also not prepared to
answer that but just in thinking about
it um seems to me if this uh body the
legislature gives uh duties via statute
to an agency to do something with
records that they could audit that
function so if they've if they've asked
an agency to to do something in that
case DHHS then they could do the
performance AIT of that and I think as
secretary scanland was mentioning there
they can give statutory obligations to
the Secretary of State's office as
insecurities um and those would be
auditable functions too so I think there
could have been a performance AIT of
some aspects of the DHHS
recordkeeping um but when the Secretary
of State uh
who as the the secretary notes always
has a role with the records uh that role
whether whether that records are
primarily housed at DHHS or at the
Secretary of State's office uh cannot by
operation of 1431a be audited um I do
think and also another problem we
identified in looking this through is
that the audit terms are pretty broad
just to say
archives um there could be uh particular
statutory obligations embedded within
but the overall breadth is such that we
think it would put the Auditors in a
very awkward position to be trying to
discern on the fly in the midst of an
audit what constitutes a constitutional
function of recordkeeping and what
constitutes a statutory so um in
weighing all that we came down um uh in
our analysis on the side that 1431a
prevents the uh performance audit of the
recordkeeping function of the Secretary
of State I just ask you one other
question certainly when we do our
budgeting um unlike with the judicial
branch we do kind of line item budgeting
of Secretary of State's office
interesting
um yeah so it's funny you mention that
so one of the cases that there's not a
lot of case law as you know and I I did
take the opportunity to look at a a
prior meeting of this group where you
had talked about the the Senate research
that had been done and there's not a
statutory definition of some of these
terms but uh in looking for uh case law
um that there was a Supreme Court case
uh Daniels versus Hansen um and they
were looking at the
Constitutional function of Sheriff's
offices and um in that case the uh the
County Commissioners set a budget and in
the budget they eliminated two deputy
sheriff's positions and the Supreme
Court basically said you can set the
budget County Commissioners but you
can't decide how many sheriff's deputies
there are that's the sheriff's
constitutional obligation so they
couldn't they were held in that case not
to be able to have a line item budget
because it encroached on the function
now they could shrink the budget if they
wanted to and maybe compel the result
they were looking for but they couldn't
specifically direct the sheriff to do
that so I don't know if that's the
closest analogous thing I could think of
but
um uh uh that that's an interesting
conundrum Senor so again the question is
a financial audit would be completely
okay but a performance audit in the case
of Records in this case would not we're
budgeting money to an agency we can make
sure that the money's being spent
appropriately whether it's a Secretary
of State's office or not that's not a
function of recordkeeping for the state
it's a function of their of of a
financial audit so if we had a financial
audit we could do that but my
understanding is
1431a D is that speak that speaks to
Performance audits or or yeah so and
that's the limitation here that's
operative so yeah yeah thank you any
other questions representative
walner
[Music]
well I um so that's an interesting
question too and and I might want to
take a look at it further before I gave
a definitive answer but off the top of
my head um the towns municipalities
they're all subsections of the state so
all their records are arguably State
records so they all sort of like the the
secretary was leaning into the fact that
even if records are housed at another
agency there's still the responsibility
of the secretary I think that that would
hold true for uh uh municipalities and
subsets of the state as well as for
executive
agencies further questions
representative you want to bring your
motion back thank you madam chair I move
that the subject of Secretary of State's
archives and Records be removed from the
performance
suggestions I I'll second that okay any
further discussion if you're in favor of
this motion would you please raise your
hand six and if you're
opposed four the motion is adopted
624 thank you thank
you
yes um representative Earth had a
question about the special education
dispute
resolution thank you madam chair
so I started on this
committee uh when Senator Reagan was
still the chair it been his final
meeting and he was I believe a driver at
least a strong proponent of the whole
special education um
audit and at that meeting in my
recollection he was very clear that the
issues that he was trying to address
were from his perspective primarily at
the the district level uh as opposed to
at the Department of Education uh
level and in going through the audit we
just released on Friday um I believe
there were over
complaints from parents that were
referenced in that audit that had been
brought to the state
level and my understanding about the
difficulty of that is that it's pretty
difficult you got to be a pretty
persistent parent to push all the way
through to getting your complaint heard
at the state level which leads me to
believe that there may be many more um
complaints that at at the district level
that are not being uh appropriately um
uh dealt
with I'm also led to believe that there
are concerns about Federal funding or
the loss of federal funding if districts
are
not appropriately
addressing these kinds of
complaints and after the last our last
meeting not the August meetings I not
president of that one but the one prior
to that when I I'm pretty sure that's
the meeting at which the scope statement
or
statements were authorized for locked
with better a word um and this
discussion came up at that point and
during the meeting my recollection is
that well we'll start with what we have
what you're doing so subsequent to that
I spoke with uh Steve Smith who I not if
I'm not mistaken that's the your your
predecessor
and I expressed my concern about the
fact that we weren't looking weren't
considering looking through to the uh
District level and he indicated that if
it appeared that was necessary that we'd
come back and and look at it and I
realize obviously we've had a change
Administration um in the LBA but it
would seem that your audit that was just
released on
Friday uh demonstrates that in fact
there is an issue um at the the district
level a pretty serious issue at the
district level that uh that we should
the auditing group should be addressing
to determine if we also have problems um
at that level and I would uh want to
encourage the committee to I understand
the one audit is completed and I'm not
to be honest I'm not exactly clear the
distinction between the two but given
that one is still ongoing it would seem
that it would be appropriate to um
expand that scope to include uh looking
through to the district
level thank you madam
chair would the LBA like to
respond hello my name is Jay Henry I'm
the um performance audit supervisor for
the LBA the current special ed audit
that's ongoing is looking at the rest of
the Department of education's special ed
Bureau and all their work so the audit
that we just finished was just at the
very end of special education it's when
there was a conflict between a parent in
the in the school over IEP or something
like that uh this other audit is
everything else and we're about halfway
through that audit it's likely to be
over 40 observations it's going to be
one of those thick audits um and we
still probably have another almost a
year to finished up that audit so to add
on another giant layer of the locals
would probably not this wouldn't be the
the audit to add it on to or we'll never
finish this topic uh the other thing I
think I'll I'll mention is that this
oversight of the district's offices or
district schools school districts um I
think we
see that the part department has much
more of a role in that than they've been
using over the years and I think you're
going to find that in this next audit
that um there could have been more
oversight by the state over the whole
process and I think you see that a
little bit also in the the audit that we
just finished so that that may address
some of the issues that you have plus
going to the school districts that gets
into
going outside of the state a agency and
we have a limitation on how many
non-state entities that we can audit
over a fiveyear term it's like I think
five over five years so we're we're
we're very limited in what non-state
entities we can go down
to of
course do you agree that the audit
you've produced demonstrates that there
is an issue at the district
level with the satisfaction of these uh
complaints from parents regarding a
special
education I don't know if we I
would well we have we said about 300
complaints that over I think a two-year
period the audit period that's out of
30,000 kids who are have an IEP so you
know it's a small percentage of all kids
what you know one concern is not
everyone maybe not every parent is
taking advantage of the dispute
resolution process and I think that's
that's uh that's true
um but I think first I think the state
needs to get its sort of house in order
I mean if you go through our the audit
that you just saw a lot of it is
informing parents and schools of what
should be happening and and that's like
a first step in trying to improve that
process thank
you
yes okay so if I understand what you're
saying it's incumbent upon the state to
try to reach out to all the parents
30,000 I guess you're referring
to to push on their
end to deal with the
districts their local districts rather
than there being any effort to push on
the districts to obey the law the
federal law which could potentially lead
to loss of funding if not followed is
that an accurate
representation no I think it's both
parents and schools I think the schools
are also
not you know they're looking at the
department they're looking at the
Department's website looking for
information and you know that's where we
found some problems with it so it's it's
not just for the parents but it's for
the whole all the
stakeholders involved in special
ed represent
Weber thank you and it it this has been
an interesting wals through um chapter
31- a but I think it is equally clear
from the language here that you're only
allowed the the authority of the uh
legislative budget assistant to conduct
post audits on non-state agencies shall
be limited to five entities in a 5-year
period and of course each individual
school district is its own entity so I
think that what I'm hearing in this
discussion is that the first step is for
the Department of Education to in
accordance with the recommendations
already made and some that are being
being made to ensure that they are
appropriately exercising the supervision
powers that they already already have
that have already been given to them in
terms of ensuring that the individual
districts are doing their job and that's
the way to
start addressing the problem and
obviously there's more work to be done
after
that Senator Whitley thank you madam
chair um and just to build off what
representative what Weber was saying I
just want to bring back into the
conversation something that we raised
with you last meeting or the meeting
before about you know just because the
audit is sort of limited in scope to
just the department of Ed that does not
mean we won't be getting information
about the districts that you know
perhaps are not meeting their
requirements under federal law and but
that's assuming that the department of
Ed is fulfilling its robust monitoring
Authority that it does have under
federal law this committee may remember
that there there is very um uh detailed
requirements in federal special ed law
about what the doe is supposed to be
doing at the district level in terms of
monitoring enforcement and so I just
wanted to confirm again that you know
your work is also looking at what you
know doe fulfilling its monitoring
Authority and if that is the case I mean
it should sort of bring up those
districts is that
correct
Senator I think Senator Whitley just hit
my point my point was I think in the
audit you just said that there's
Authority that the Department's not
using that it can use that would
probably resolve some of the local
issues and I think it's now time that's
it's been identified that the department
can use that Authority maybe that'll
start resolving some of the issues so I
I think that's what you said if I'm not
mistaken is that there's Authority the
Department's not using on local school
boards or local school districts that it
could and you pointed it out hopefully
they'll take that to heart and start
doing that which will resolve some of
the local issues I think we're going to
get a big audit A thick one at the end
of the year is what I heard Madam chair
yes might it be possible to see the D if
the department has any response to what
we've been hearing here yes if there are
no more questions of the LBA on this
issue okay don't go away does the
department good morning commissioner
good morning for the record Frank ad
Commissioner of education and I'm not
trying to have a groundhog day here
because we spent quite a bit of time
talking about the scope um at the time
we spoke about the scope I was quite
clear that I believe that uh the audit
as it was configured was not responsive
to the concerns that originally put this
audit on the table to begin with uh when
Senator Reagan was being responsive to
uh a number of issues that individual
families from the field brought to us uh
we appreciate that the LBA believes we
have this superpower uh we have yet to
find a district that agrees with that or
a district attorney that agrees with
that so while they believe that we
somehow can just ask for this
information or demand this information
um you know here to for it has not been
forthcoming um I would also just like to
point out there's incorrectness in terms
of the limitation on the LBA if you read
their statute uh they are not limited in
terms of five entities when it's
referenced to uh school districts
because those are political subdivisions
right they are part of the state and so
that statute does not limit them in that
regard is our understanding of the
statute so just as they're explaining to
me how my statutes work I'm going to
explain to them I believe how their
statutes work and uh and again um you
know we think that the uh here's what
happens is so there are ating all of the
information that comes to me right which
is a very small subset of the issues
relative to special education to happen
in the field and we don't even know
about many of these issues because they
never come to our attention we don't see
those issues coming
in if a school district um you know is
not providing uh appropriate services
and persuades a parent that it's okay or
to just be quiet or go away uh we're not
going to know about that we don't get
the complaint like if we get these 300
complaints we deal with them with the
tools that we have but the concern that
was raised initially was all of the
stuff that doesn't reach us because of
uh potentially poor oversight poor
implementation at the district level and
so I think that was the original inent
from Senator Reagan um I think that's
the original attent from the
constituents who had reached out um but
we understand that uh we've had this
hearing but so so those are my comments
relative to the conversation here today
thank
you I one question yes Senator that so
just one
question actually one second um Melissa
white division director for learner
support I think just one key point I
wanted to add is that the state
contributes
$225,000 for the administration of
special education to the department so
the only part that the state is
contributing to the operation this
includes dispute resolution and all that
of pieces of special education is
$225,000 so we are at times limited in
our Focus because we have to prioritize
the federal requirements because the
federal government is paying to meet
those requirements so I think it's just
key to delineate how much the state is
actually
contributing my simple question was
around reporting right so is is there a
is there a requirement of a school
district report the number of complaints
and at all to this to the uh departments
like we've received a th000 and
complaints from parents on relative to
special education is there any kind of
reporting requirement that we have so we
can gauge whether what three how 300
ratios to the total number of complaints
that were received thank you for the
question we do not collect that number
what we do uh collect is that they have
a special education dispute resolution
process that they can provide to us and
so we can look at that that must be
implemented but we do not go in and look
at their actual number of
complaints
where was that
hand rep
no Senator Whit thank you madam chair
and thank you again for coming up um can
you describe how you so what I'm hearing
is that you you don't hear about the
problems at the district level unless
you got a complaint from a parent can
you describe to us about how you all um
comply with the Ida regulations about
establishing requirements for State
monitoring enforcement and annual
reporting how do you comply to those
requirements if you're only hearing
complaints that they come to you yep so
we do do monitoring and I'm going to let
Melissa um speak to that but I was
thinking I would share an example of you
know so that you see how kind of actual
things sort of unfold in the field and
how it may or may not come to us so um
and this is a complaint that we received
um but it was after quite a bit of
process had already taken place uh so
there was a p a particular family uh the
mother had a uh kindergartener who had
gone through kindergarten at the end of
the school year she believed that there
was some issues with her young child uh
not necessarily sure how to articulate
those but was concerned about them and
asked the school to hold her child back
and in typical Fashions the school did
not hold the child back insisted that
the kid move along to first grade how
the parent again believing that there
were issues with her child that she
wanted to to deal with uh pulled the kid
out of school and started home educating
the student
During the period of home education and
again this is all hindsight we didn't
know none of this is happening right so
there's this conflict at the school
district I want my kid to stay back
school says no parents pulled out
department has no knowledge of this
taking place while the kid is
homeschooling mom continues to be
concerned about the development of the
child um while she's homeschooling in
January of that year so initially pulled
out in like the late August September
time frame uh goes out on her own dime
and has some neurological evaluations
performed relative to her child because
she's that concerned about the
development of her kid um she continues
to homeschool she's not making progress
she's concerned about her child she
reenroll her child into special
education or into the public school
system um and she asks for evaluations
uh she brings her neurological
evaluations to The District in about the
May time frame uh they convene a team to
look at this child and determine what's
up and they say not eligible for special
education but we will do some
evaluations um the parent asked for a
specific evaluation say I need this type
of an evaluation because I think this is
the appropriate one the school says we
don't do those but we'll do these
evaluations so the school did those
evaluations and came back and concluded
in August that um the child was not
eligible for special education based on
those evaluations they did not perform
the evaluation that the parent had asked
for um child continues in school and in
the fall they we get around to
completing the evaluations for the child
that the mother was seeking and by
January the child has an IEP and is
getting the supports and services that
they need and so my concern is um and
then the parent files a complaint with
me probably I think I'm dealing with it
at this point in time so uh you know
months later at this point in time right
like so I'm in March now and so my
concern is that until that parent filed
a complaint with me that the special
education process had not been followed
I would have no knowledge of that
process not necessarily being followed
Even in our monitoring of the school
district we're not going in and looking
at every individual case we're looking
at the policies and procedures that the
school district has in place and so if
that school district and and our job is
not to second guess the IEP team per se
but here's an example of how is it that
we as a district and I don't I don't
have any authority to override the
district even in this complaint but how
is it that you know a parent on four
separate occasion raises red flags and
says something's not right can somebody
help me and the system is not responsive
to it so those the concerns that I have
and then specific to your question I'll
let U Melissa talk about um you know our
school monitoring process the special
education um Bureau oversees the
monitoring for U meeting all of the idea
requirements and so we do have a robust
team internally that is um conducting
that monitoring there was a different
system that was set in place in a dist a
different monitoring process we have
since um Becky fet the director of
special education and myself have um
come into our positions we've
re-evaluated that system and we are
working with the US Department of
Education and specifically uh the office
of special education programs at the
federal level to um re-evaluate our
monitoring system and to implement a
more robust uh system in that work so
just to give you a little bit of
background on that so essentially so uh
Santina used to run the special
education department she hadd been
running it for 15 years and she had a
certain monitoring uh protocol that she
was following that had approved had been
approved by used um Santina left and
went to a district and we hired Becky
fet who is now running the department
she came in she says I think there's a
more effective way to do it and so what
she's referring to is the change over in
like between 2018 and 2020 um of the
monitoring system follow up yes thank
you so commissioner you said that
monitoring as sort of limited you can't
look at individual files that it's
limited to just policies but the
requirements under Ida is that your
monitoring actually has to focus on
improving educational results and
functional outcomes for all children
with disabilities so how do you comply
with that requirement so you mis yeah so
you just misunderstood when I said I
don't look at if you're only looking at
policy so hold on how can you do that if
you're not actually looking at
individual cases because they're pretty
rigorous requirements yeah so what I was
referring to when I made that statement
was the example that I talked about so I
would like to lean in on that specific
example and ask the school to uh you
know do something specific about it but
in fact we only are able to in that
complaint process identify technical
non-compliance as opposed to the fact
that we have a kid who's not getting the
SE supports and services that we need
and I don't know if you want to go into
the detail about the actual monitoring
because it includes files obviously so
when we're looking at Improvement
results for special education students
specifically we do look at um rely
pretty heavily on our assessment data
and so we'll go in and look at that
assessment data and then we have an A a
process where for example if we notice a
specific school is um having results
that are maybe below average or they're
not making a lot of improvement with
their special education subpopulation we
will go in and work through targeted
support interventions to do and it's a
specific TSI CSI process where schools
are identified we will go in we will
work with those schools we hire
contractors to work with those schools
um one of the ones we use right now is
westad they have a pretty robust system
that they will go in and work with that
team to specifically the leadership and
also that the teachers in that school to
look specifically at that subpopulation
and say okay what are you know the
trends that we're noticing what
interventions can we help you to
implement what changes need to be made
at that school level in order to support
those students and that list is
available on our website we identify
those schools on an annual basis so that
is one of the ways that we work in
particular with our special education
monitoring process what we have in place
now is looking maybe more specifically
let's say for example we have a school
district that has um over 1% of their
population identified as needing um
having intensive uh cognitive needs
usually the Federal Department of
Education identifies no more than 1% of
your special education population is
identified so if we notice the school
district has more we will go in we will
work with them to ensure that they're
properly identifying students maybe
there are students that don't
necessarily qualify and we work with
them um so that's an example of some
sort of targeted support that we will go
in and give on that specific issue but
if we're looking at that student level
like one student in a district with an
issue we may not know some specifics
around that unless we have a complaint
coming from a parent and then it might
be specific ific to that student so it
it varies across the board but for the
most part we have um systems in place in
different programs that look at the
special education needs and if I may
just again uh you know I've already
vetted my concerns about the way that
this AED is scoped and I appreciate the
conversation so um can I ask you made a
surprising point about the amount of
money the state budgets 200
25,000 to oversee special education
which doesn't sound like a
lot has the department ever asked for an
increase in that line yes so the
increases that we've sought in special
education when I first got to the
department we were funding special
education for the districts at about
72% um we
sought and I think with the help of
Representative
Wier excuse me
uh were awarded additional funds up to
34 million so now we are fully funding
that at the district district level I'm
sorry the man the Department's so we
have not I don't no we have not s in
oversite we actually the the thing that
we've advocated for is really to provide
additional supports to the field because
we think that's the priority
funding do you feel you have
the resource ources to
oversee those local issues that
representative Earth is concerned about
so the it would be difficult to oversee
some of those state laws because a lot
of these are state funded items and so
we don't have the ability to oversee
those with federal funds unless there's
an overlap between the state obligation
and the federal obligation um again so
our approach has been how do we provide
more resources to provide services to
students is what we've been seeking
thanks rep
webner my turn for Groundhog Day
okay what I'm hearing in representative
Rosen wald's question
is that we have a very small amount of
specific State funding for specific
State
monitoring and oversight and what I was
hearing her ask you and what I want to
know the answer
to is do we need to be changing that
amount so that there is a more robust
ability in your department to do the
monitoring that we have been talking
about it's nothing to do with the
overall Federal funding it's just our
state funding and state oversight
absolutely and if we're looking at also
introducing new legislation that has new
requirements within special education
that are not mirrored in federal um law
then we have to allocate funding for for
us in order to do that the 225,000
includes complaint
investigators so we're having to use
that fund also to contract for those
complaint investigators that are
specific to the dispute resolution
process and I think what I heard was the
department has not asked for more
resources the the additional funding
we've saw has only been through the
field right represent Weber so there
might be a request in another budget
cycle to make that function more robust
thank you for the question I think um in
looking at the dispute resolution audit
in addition to the special education
audit that will help us to then
prioritize what our needs could be I
think we do want to take a look at so
expect a prioritize need is what she
just said
excellent any further questions
on this audit topic which is
halfway
through thank you thank you don't go
away okay what's next
Jay we moving on to uh the
required audit of the education Freedom
account
program excuse me I just a one thing one
sort of housekeeping thing um the the
audit that that you decided to stall the
Secretary of State's audit of of
archives that that went through fiscal
the last time that this body stopped an
audit uh they also sent a letter to
fiscal informing them of that so I I
just want to make you aware that we
should the chair should write a letter
to to give to fiscal informing them that
this audit has been discontinued do you
have a template I I will I will get one
for
you thank you thank you and FIS we just
meant in fiscal so you got almost four
weeks thank
you okay moving on to the education
Freedom accounts audit uh chapter 297
laws of
2022 uh which was effective on October
1st of
23 and uh we did provide the members
with a handout on that um that requires
a performance audit of the education
Freedom account
program uh the law requires us to submit
a uh scope statement to this committee
for review and approval uh we had an
entrance conference with the Department
on January
9th we currently have three Auditors
assigned to that audit who've been busy
gathering information to plan for the
audit and uh to start work on developing
that scope
statement during the information
gathering process we ran into a
challenge uh something that we call a
scope limitation in auditing uh that we
wanted to inform the committee about as
it does significantly affect our ability
to move forward with the audit as
directed in the law and uh I'll explain
now the department contracts with a
third party uh the children's
scholarship fund to administer the
program contract Provisions state that
all data including reports files
computer programs notes letters papers
and documents Etc under the contract are
the property of the state and are owned
by the department uh the scholarship
organizations required to provide that
information to the department as
requested by the department in
accordance with the
contract this includes any data that the
scholarship organization has developed
acquired or obtained while administering
the
program these Provisions appear to allow
the department to request information
from The Scholar ship Organization for
the Department's own oversight
activities and for purposes of the
audit it's the Department's position
that the chapter law only gives our
office the authority to audit the
Department's oversight of the program so
according to the department the law does
not give the LBA the authority to audit
the scholarship organization because the
law does not specifically mention the
contractor
the department is willing to provide us
with all program documentation that it
has in its possession but it will not
assist with obtaining the data and
documents needed for the audit from the
scholarship organization as according to
the department this would violate the
separation of powers between the
legislative and executive
branches this creates a substantial
scope limitation on the audit
much of the items listed in the chapter
law in items a through G cannot be
audited without access to the state
records and documents in the possession
of the scholarship
organization if the committee would like
some further details on what items we
would not be able to audit um I have the
senior manager here that could go down
the list and uh let you know which items
we would not be able to
audit right
bmer so my brain just started to
bounce thank you for taking my question
sir am I understanding that the
department has taken the
position that
because a function that was originally
given to the department has been
contracted out as the department May of
course
do
that
we now have no authority
to do the audit because of a separation
of powers argument that seems to me to
be very attenuated and I realize you're
probably not the person to ask and I
certainly will ask that question of the
department as well but it and the mind
still sitting in the back I think right
this this audit is different from other
performance audits because the authority
to uh perform the audit is in a separate
chapter law it doesn't follow the normal
process um that we would typically
follow in conducting a performance audit
where the committee would give us an
audit topic and then we would go ahead
and and perform that audit this
particular audit was established under
that chapter law and I think the
Department's position is that because
the chapter law doesn't spec spe
specifically mention that uh scholarship
organization that uh our office does not
have the authority to um audit the
scholarship
organization follow
on so would I be correct in thinking
that um under that argument that this
body would have the authority to um
expand the scope of what was put into
statute to make it clear that the
organization would be um required to
provide the information needed for an
appropriate
audit I think it could require an
amendment to the chapter law um in order
for us to obtain those those records to
perform the audit and um review the
items in a through G listed in the
chapter
law one yes and then thank you very much
thank you for
going with me on the journey uh but one
of the things I was thinking to make
things somewhat easier because we all
know how long the process takes to amend
uh a statute as opposed to having this
body make uh a decision um could this
body choose
to
um not NE not amend the statute but
simply
require
additional steps to be
taken I think that could potentially be
an option um you know there's a couple
of different options I think one could
be we
could complete the audit of this chapter
law um based on what information we can
audit and then issue a report to comply
with the chapter law uh that report
would be very limited um because we we
can't review much of the information
that's held by the scholarship
organization um I think possibly another
option is to have this committee um come
up with a new audit scope and uh have
the um audit scope include a review of
the documents at the scholarship
organization uh I'm not sure if there's
other legal issues that you'd have to um
consider in doing that um but that would
be the committee's
decision rep wler thank you madam chair
having read all your audits for the more
than 20 years I don't recall any that
ever delved into a
contractor and many of our functions
especially in Dees or de DH
HHS are done with contractors and we
rely on the
agency to monitor to the contractors and
so this would be an expansion that I'm
not in support of to go after
contractors and get down to that level
that is done by much of the state work
but is not uh looked at by the audit
division so much as by the department
that gives the contracts so I'm not in
support of of this bill trying to go
into that level and I don't think it's
correct thank you
representative
Griffin it would thank you madam chair
it would seem to me that um the contract
would have to
specifically call for that ability
otherwise I don't I don't see how you
get into a
contractor's
organization I would think from a
financial standpoint you might be able
to turn obtain their audit report and
rely on that but on a performance uh
basis I would think you'd have to have
specific language in the contract in
order to be able to do
that representative
Reber um I'm informed without having
been able to check it that the chapter
law when this was passed um
specified that the how the scholarship
organization is to be
audited and I wonder if that changes
anybody's opinion about
anything but the issue of transparency
here is clearly first and foremost in
everybody's
mind could you just clarify
that um I think an audit typically is
I'm a CPA so I'm pretty familiar with
Audits and typically an audit is a
financial audit and I would think it
would be proper to ask the the
organization to send a copy of their
financial audit but when you get into
performance audits I think that's a
whole different ball
game rep Weber if I may what we were
told was that unless the statute had
specifically
authorized looking at the scholarship
organization it could not be done and
what I'm asking is if anybody has taken
a look at the chapter law because I
certainly haven't to see if it contains
such a specific
authorization it doesn't right so again
if you look at the 11:35 which is on
here the question is on line three right
it says that the audit division of the
legisl shall complete a performance
audit of the Department of Education so
the question is going to take another
step down not given the explicit
Authority and I I guess I'm agreeing
with with representative uh wheeler
there that you don't you can't take that
step down we we've authorized only the
data that's within their control and we
can do performance audit on that data
but I'm not sure there's legislative
authority to take a step down but so
what I'm confused about is I don't see
any directive in the chapter law
that wants us to look at the
contractor the intention of the statute
which which by the way went through the
house on the consent calendar and a
Voice vote in the Senate was very
clearly to monitor the department and as
I'm looking
at um a through
G um so a is initial and continued
eligibility of
participants doesn't the department
presumably have a
procedure that we
could audit as to whether or not they
were maintaining proper
oversight of people being eligible and B
is controls for
determining qualifying expenditures I'd
be
shocked if the department did not
have a policy and procedure for
that and just looking at all of them
they're basic
management over sight of a program that
I think we expect all of our
departments to have
on every
program representative if I may I'd like
to ask um the senior manager to come up
and just go through the list of items
that we would not be able to audit
without further access to the records at
the scholarship organization okay
Senator L um yeah well it's not a
question it's just a statement again
under uh 194f R Ral 15 says the
department shall adopt rules that are
necessary for the administration of this
chapter and the chapter is EFA program
and the scholarship program so I I would
anticipate that a performance audit
would look at the rules that they've
adopted for the administration of that
program and whether or not they're
following those rules
uh that go along with that um so there
is some provision again again within the
agency and it's rules that's done to to
implement the law and a performance
audit whether or not it's following a
the law and B the rules well and in
order to do that you'd think that the
department would have to get information
from the
contractor possibly again that's up to
the agency and again if it's it's it's
information within the agency I think
they'd be obligated to turn it over it's
information outside the agency I'm not
sure they're obligated to to chase it
down because again we're doing that step
down into another layer of auditing that
isn't even authorized by the statute
again the authorization the the 1135
authorizes us to to audit them not the
scholarship program but the contract
makes clear that all of the data about
this program belongs to the
state yes good morning um I did I'm
sorry I don't know who asked the
question about the Department's
monitoring but uh we have asked about
the Department's monitoring introduce
yourself oh I'm
sorry uh I'm vay skids uh the senior
audit manager that's uh been put on this
audit um as I was saying the we have
asked the department about their
monitoring efforts and right now those
efforts are in its infant stages um
currently the EFA administrator he
hasn't been in his position for it's
been about a year and he started some
monitoring um so right now he has been
looking at some of the El eligibility
pieces but he hasn't finished with his
report yet so we haven't gotten that
report um and as far as the second piece
um qualifying expenditures he has just
started that process so we don't have
access to their monitoring pieces yet
because they're not
complete so but
so it doesn't say when the audit
has to be done just that
the law went into effect October 1 cor
right um and uh like Christine had said
I can go through some of the pieces that
we won't be able to look at um based on
the current uh situation so you all have
a copy of uh HB 1135 or chapter 297 in
front of you so I'll just go through
each of those um points so the first pie
piece is the initial and continued
eligibility of participants so without
the information that's at the
scholarship organization we wouldn't be
able to determine whether policies
procedures and other internal guidance
that uh is used by the scholarship
organization conformed to state laws or
rules we would not be able to determine
whether participants were eligible to
receive the base uh EFA Grant we would
not be able to review participants
continued eligibility to participate in
the EFA program including whether
participants continue to meet residency
age
requirements we would not be able to
perform audit work to determine whether
students who were not previously
enrolled in public school were eligible
to receive initial differentiated Aid
and we would not be able to perform work
to review of participants continued to
meet requirements for differentiated AG
Aid each
year um continuing on to Item B controls
for determining qualifying expenditures
we would not be able to determine
whether policy procedures other internal
guidance that are used by the
scholarship organization conformed to
laws state laws or rules we would not be
able to determine whether specific
purchases and expenses for individual
efas align with statutes and
rules um item C identification and
recovery of ineligible dispersements we
would not be able to determine whether
again policies procedures conform to
state laws and rules we would not be
able to determine whether participants
receiving EFA funds met all eligibility
criteria at the time of application or
continue to meet eligibility criteria uh
for receiving differentiated Aid so a
lot of the same limitations that we've
I've outlined in A and B apply to this
one as
well item D procedures and controls for
transferring funds to the scholarship
organization we would not be able to
determine whether funds were paid to
students who did not meet all
eligibility requirements at the time of
their application we would not be able
to determine whether funds transferred
to the scholarship organization
uh were distributed to uh were credited
to the correct individual
efas um item e procedures and controls
for phase out grants this is an area
that uh the department um does so we
don't foresee limitations in this
area uh item F public parti public
reporting of participation student
outcomes and
expenditures uh student outcome data uh
is not maintained at the department so
we wouldn't be able to review those and
then item G demographics of qualifying
applicants uh the municipality states of
residence grade level type of location
type in location of educational programs
during those two years uh we would not
be able to identify the type and
location of the educational programs the
students are current currently enrolled
in and we would not be able to determine
whether students still reside in the
municipality they did when they
initially applied for an
EA
questions Senor with yeah
um so thank you for this information you
know it is pretty it takes my breath
away a little bit that the state is our
taxpayers are spending millions and
millions and millions of dollars on a
program that's a that's going to a
private organization and it's a complete
Black Box and that you're telling us
that we have absolutely practically no
uh opportunity to you know exercise our
duties to make sure that taxpayer
dollars are being spent appropriately it
sounds like that's what you're telling
us yes um and I'd also like to add that
the scholarship organization is willing
to assist with the audit as long as they
receive the Department's prior written
approval which is required under Section
10.3 of the contract otherwise according
to the scholarship organization they
cannot permit access to the data as it
would violate the
contract um what pages that of the
contract
uh you know that's all
right so did I hear you say that the
management of this program At Doe is
just new
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry um so the EFA
administrator the position was
authorized I believe June or July of
2022 and um the EFA administrator was
hired at the end of March 2023 so he's
been here for about a year so it's still
early
correct questions representative B uh
thank you madam chair actually there's a
couple of comments on a motion if I
might so I just want to point out that
if I heard you correctly you're talking
about um expanding the scope of the um
audit whereas in the previous comments
the pre discussion about special
education that's seem to be out of the
realm of consideration which is number
one and number two here you want
to go and audit the contractor a third
party private third party again going
back to the previous conversation about
special education you explicitly stated
it may not have been the two of you but
the
organization um that you wouldn't
consider auditing what were actually
government entities in terms of the
local school districts so I just you
don't need to respond to that unless you
want
to I just wanted to clarify you
mentioned that
um our office wanted to audit the
contractor I'm not quite sure that's the
situation I think our um you know intent
here was just to let you know that we
cannot continue with much of the audit
unless we were given access to that
information and that is that's the
decision of the committee um so I just
wanted to clarify that follow follow
okay follow up thank you for that
clarification because that's that
actually goes to my
point that
you
didn't want to go um audit the
contractor and yet when we talk about
the school boards you specifically don't
want to audit I mean not school boards
the school districts you specifically
don't want to um out of the contractors
so that's fine I think I've made my
point that and you've made your point
which is fantastic may I make a motion
Madam chair I'd like to hear from the
Department thank you and also the
Attorney General's office
first thank
you representative Weber has a question
that's okay I'm going to have some
comments first I think it be to start us
off because I think there's some
information that is inaccurate that's
out on the table that I think I can
clarify um thank you and 12:30 is at
risk at this point don't you
think uh so if you didn't make comments
questions perhaps 12:30 wouldn't be at
risk okay I'm G to hand out a handout so
make sure that you get one of these
handouts if you might it is a section of
the contract that was referred to a
number of times and I will get to that
you don't have to um grab it immediately
but um in essence part of the
conversation here comes down to the
ownership of data who's who owns this
data that is being sought um the
enabling legislation in 1135 and I'm
happy to go through that in a couple of
different ways um with you um seems
quite clear the legislative budget
assistant shall complete a performance
audit of the department of education
education Freedom account program this
is an audit of the department it is not
an audit of the vendor of the department
uh this audit needs to be directed at
the processes at the department and I'm
happy to go through 1135 and explain to
you why I believe that they can meet the
obligation their obligation under 1135
um auditing the department um and really
the Constitutional argument which I'll
reference again a couple different times
comes from you know the legislative
branch ordering the executive branch to
seek information that it does not own
from a vendor uh right and so that is uh
really what we see as one of the
substantive problems here but again just
to give you a little background January
9th we Pro we had our our initial
opening meeting uh the LBA audit
division uh first gave us a request for
information uh for documents that are
not owned um were in the possession of
the state and uh you know the department
communicated to the Auditors at that
time that we believe that the audit
scope included the department and not
the vendors of the department uh
February 13th the department
communicated that we would not be
seeking documents that were not property
of the state and not in the possession
of the state uh we further communicated
that the department could not be
compelled to seek such information right
the audit the LBA Auditors don't get to
come over to the executive branch to say
we want you to go get something that's
not yours um in effect this is that
separation of powers argument on
February when they were no they were
that was on February 13th on February
27th without the knowledge no knowledge
by the department the auditor sent an
email directly to the children's
scholarship fund indicating that they
believe that they had author it to
obtain this information didn't talk to
the department didn't seek our advice or
whether we believed that we owned it or
didn't um and we believe that the
Auditors wrongfully stated that all data
in the possession of the children's
scholarship fund were the property of
the state and subject to the audit on
March 8th as a result of the faulty
information that the Auditors provided
to the children's scholarship fund the
children's scholarship fund stated that
if the department gives us permission
then we can give this to you but again
we don't even believe that it is our
information so we can't take you know we
don't need to Grant permission for that
as I'll walk you through the contract in
a moment and then finally on uh on March
14th um the children's scholarship fund
clarified to us their position that the
materials were not the property of their
state and not subject to delivery of the
state and quite frankly um just the
auditor's inquiry into the children's
scholarship fund created a bit of
organizational turmoil I'd now like you
to turn your attention to uh the handout
that I gave you and again the relevant
question here is whether the student and
family data in the possession of the
children's scholarship fund is the
property of the State uh New Hampshire
Ed the department believes that such
data is not the property of the state
when the enabling legislation what for
this program was first established the
legislature deliberately separated the
functions of the state New Hampshire
Department of Education and a
scholarship organization to whom much of
the responsibility for the
administration of the program was
delegated
uh the statute is quite clear about the
various obligations for each of those
entities given this direction in the
legislature uh New Hampshire the
Department of Education entered into a
contract with the children's scholarship
fund the terms of this contract
establish that at a minimum personally
identifiable data generated by this
contract is the property of the
children's scholarship fund or not but
certainly not the state's property um if
this were not the case New Hampshire
Department of Education would have
required a number of contractual
Provisions relative to uh the protection
of person ID identifiable information
including all of the doit contract
specifications and the governor and
Council would have required such things
as well finally in its ongoing
relationship with the children's
scholarship funds including monitoring
the program thank you Senator Rosen um
you know the uh the children's
scholarship fund has continue to assert
that this is not property of the uh the
state um now in on uh February 27th the
Auditors sent an email and made an
assertion that the data held by the
children's scholarship fund was property
of the state such assertion contradicts
new H the Department's understanding of
the contract and contradicts uh these
actions the legislative actions as well
as the actions uh of how we've operated
for the first three years and if you'll
notice in the email that um the auditor
sent initially
and I'll pull this up they point to
paragraph 10.1 which is in the handout
that you have you all have 10.1 and if
you read 10.1 10.1 States a very broad
uh you know um cast a very broad net it
says as used in this agreement the word
data shall mean all information and
things developed or obtained during the
performance of or acquired or developed
by reason of this agreement including
but not limited to all studies reports
files formula surveys Maps charts sound
recordings video recordings pictorial
reproductions drawings analytics graphic
representations computer programs
computer printouts notes letters I
assume that could mean emails uh
memorandum papers and documents all
whether finished or unfinished and then
in the second thing if you read if you
continue the assertion was that well
this is data therefore must be property
of the state and so they go to 10.2 and
it says all data and any property which
has been received from the state or
purchased with funds provided for that
purpose under this agreement shall be
the property of the state and shall be
returned to the state upon demand or
upon termination of this agreement for
any reason um and then they point in 20
in three that the the data can be
disclosed upon written uh approval so
NHS understanding of this contractual
provision which is consistent with both
its and the actions of the children's
scholarship fund to date are that the
property does not belong to the state it
reads look at Care at uh 10.2 very
carefully it reads all data and property
which has been received from the state
or purchased with funds provided for
that purpose under this agreement and
that is a very standard contractual term
um notice that it doesn't say all data
Comm it says all data and property which
has been received so it's modified IED
there um so V seems to think that all
data in 10.1 as well as any property
which has been received from the state
or purchase with funds provided for that
purpose under this agreement is property
of the state and this contradicts Common
Sense quite frankly it results in just
an absurd application under the contract
which no one's going to believe right
they're basically saying imagine if I
went to all of my contractors and said
all the emails that you ever wrote about
this contract those are the property of
the state every note that you took in a
meeting relative this contract that
becomes property of the state that's not
can't possibly be the meaning associated
with this and everybody knows that in a
typical contract right you have a
contract and we're saying like all data
that we give you and all data that we
pay for you to develop that's the
property of the state not all data
associated with this contract and so New
Hampshire believes that all data and
property are modified by received from
the state or purchase blah BL blah such
reading is the practical application of
the language that any data provided to
the vendor or purchased on behalf of the
contract can be demanded by the state
and must be returned to the state upon
termination um and this understanding is
also grammatically correct again it
doesn't State all data comma and any
property but States all data and
property without the comma establishing
that the modifier of which has been
received from the state or purchased
with funds provided for that purpose
applies to both data and property right
they're not trying to sweep up
everything that's ever happened at the
uh at the you know from the agreement
and quite frankly this entire thing
could have if the Auditors had
communicated with us and talked to us we
could have clarified this for them um
and so imagine the Absurd application
that would mean that I have a contract
with tutor.com can I go to tutor.com and
say like I want all of the personal
identifiable information of every
student and teacher that has ever done
tutoring of course I can't right I
didn't provide that data how about if I
go to discovery.com I got 1.2 million
teachers and Educators using that
program across the state and allowed to
go to Discovery and say I want every
single email that's ever been written I
think that that's an absurd application
of this contract and and and quite
frankly doesn't make any sense and then
I just want to I want to step back again
as well and just reflect on additional
scoping relative to this audit I was
shocked to learn the other day that the
Auditors have sought access from the
Department's food and nutrition program
under the premise that they can learn
something from how schools qualify
students for free and reded and reduced
price meal eligibility and quite frankly
I don't know why they're there they have
now sought and met with my reading
Specialists they've s and met again with
special education as if those guys
haven't been audited twice already is
enough um and so like I just am
concerned that we are almost it feels
like a little bit of a fishing
Expedition I'm going to tell you how
they can meet their obligations in a
moment but then the last thing that I
will talk about is and this was quite
disturbing is that it was communicated
to staff of the department that when the
Auditors want to interview with staff
members it is not permissible to have
their supervisor present and the belief
was that they didn't want the supervisor
present because maybe they would not say
something they would be you know feel
like they have to be nefarious or
something quite frankly we're trying to
work with the Auditors to make sure that
we roll out an effective program that
serves the needs of the students and I I
take offense at that um you know kind of
a policy and i' I've worked in this
field for many many years and I can tell
you that of course you want the a the if
a supervisor thinks they need to be
there to make sure that the Auditors get
accurate information that should be the
case if the supervisor thinks that the
individual is has you know been in the
job long enough to be able to do it they
can go ahead and do it but now if I come
back to uh 11:35 you know the Auditors
of the department and the if you look
through these things the initial and
continued eligibility of departments we
have a monitoring program that is
monitoring both the initial and the
continued eligibility of IND individuals
in the department and we are doing that
we have controls to determine that the
expenses that are being approved are
qualified we have procedures and
controls for transferring funds to the
scholarship or actually I skipped one uh
controls for determining qualifying
expense identify and recovering
ineligible expenses every year we go
through a very extensive reconciliation
with the scholarship organization and
they're happy to come in they can see
all the documentation we have relative
to that and they can take a look at it
um you know procedures and controls for
transferring FRS to the scholarship
organization again I have to authorize
that transfer I sign off on it there is
plenty of documentation that takes place
at the department R to to my sign off to
make sure that the amount of funds that
we're transferring is the appropriate
amount and then the subsequent
reconciliations to make sure that we
know where those funds ended up um you
know public reporting in terms of
participation student outcomes and
expenditures we have quite a bit of
public reporting uh we release
demographic reports on a regular basis
so I believe that there is plenty of
audit available and I believe that they
can meet their obligations and we
believe that the statute does not allow
them to go to a vendor and seek
information that is not the property of
the state um and so those are my my
comments before I recognize Senator
Whitley for question yes I just want to
say that I think all of us in this room
have deep respect for the
professionalism of the
LBA both the budget Division and the
audit division and I am sure you are not
implying anything other than that
absolutely not 100% I have the same
respect and I actually think that this
can be a real opportunity to try and
make sure that we're implementing a
program a new program for the state in
its infancy so to speak um to be able to
make sure that we set it on a right
course from the beginning and I share
that that interest and I'm happy to kind
of work toward W that uh I am concerned
when there are engagements with my staff
there are engagements with vendors that
seem to go beyond that and and lack some
degree of communication Senator Whitley
thank you madam chair I that was a in my
opinion a full scale attack on the LBA
and I would like them to come up and
respond please because I I think that's
very appropriate before we do additional
question we do that I just want to ask
you about section 10.2 yes
the way I read it that little or in the
second line is little but it's
incredibly powerful because it puts
equal weight on what comes before it and
what comes after it because it is not a
restrictive Clause so all data and any
property which has been received from
the
state is one and two or has been
purchased with funds provided for the
purpose under this
agreement is has equal weight to shall
be the property of the state so I I
think you're misreading it
grammatically
which we could we could argue grammar
but i' probably spend more time teaching
writing than you actually I ma'am could
you introduce yourself I can Elizabeth
Brown I'm Council for the Department of
Education and I actually think your
reading actually AIDS the department
even more than um our prior reading
because if you read that it's if that is
or purchased with funds for the state
it's it has to be data or property
received from the state and I'm going to
take a little step back and I actually
will then will give you all a handout
because this statute is very different
the way the program for the EFA program
was designed by the legislature is very
different than probably any other
program that is being administered in
the state the department has a couple of
obligations under this statute and the
scholarship organization by Design and
the legislature designed this
program um gave the scholarship
organization a number of duties and
responsibilities with respect to
administering the program
and you can see that um very clearly in
194 F4 um Roman numeral F1 Roman numeral
7 which basically says the scholarship
or organization is the um Department
that implements and administers the one
night the program so I think this is
this is a bit different and this is why
it is um important to understand that
this whole program is set up by the
legislature in order to bifurcate the
information because the scholarship
organization is receiving like because I
don't think this is made this point has
been made here either by the legislators
or by my uh commissioner the type of
information that the scholarship
organization has is deeply personal and
deeply private and I believe that is why
the legislature in their Prudence
decided to bifurcate this the
information that the EFA administrator
has the scholarship organization has is
student data and tax returns from our
taxpayers in order to determine whether
or not they're eligible that is not the
kind of information that our department
manages ever we don't have student level
data we don't have individual taxpayer
information and I actually think our
taxpayers might be somewhat offended if
they found out that we had General
access to that information this was put
behind the the protections of the
scholarship organization in order to
keep that information private and to
keep it out of the hands of the
government that was done by Design um so
I just want to make sure that I that I
actually believe your reading is also
consistent with our reading that that
information those tax returns and that
uh student information is not government
information and that data does never
become data of the department because we
did not purchase it um and it was
provided directly by individual
taxpayers and parents to the scholarship
organization and order to determine
their children's eligibility for the
program and that was all by the design
of the legislature if I could I would
hand out uh 194f copies just for your
information um if you can please take
one I think so you wouldn't be able to
get deidentified
data on where where the students lived
or what the income
levels were so the the the the 800 r and
we may be answering this slightly
differently but the so one of our
obligations under 194f was to develop
administrative rules we did that the
administrative rules that are applicable
to the EFA program you can find in
ed800 under ed800 there are certain
reporting requirements of the
scholarship organization back to the
department and includes much of the
information that you are asking
for
so you can get the information for the
audit we're it's clear that the bill
that was passed does not ask for an
audit of the scholarship
oration it ask for an audit of the
Department's oversight that's clear I
don't think anyone is
suggesting that there's an intention to
go so we agree I I I don't see that any
where who a
question oh Senator Lang and then Weber
and then I I just have a procedural
question about where we're going with
this committee and this conversation
because again um this is a statutory
audit right so it's not whether or not
we want to do the audit we have to do
the AIT we have to do the audit right
right now we're
we right now we're trying to play parent
between two siblings it sounds like
between the LBA and the and the and the
doe and trying to referee what is in
scope and what's out of scope um so I
guess my question is what's the role of
this Committee in this conversation um
we've approved the scope LBA has it they
should complete the audit as much as
they can with the data that they're
willing to provide if they want to do
something with the Department then
that's their obligation to do it I'm
just trying to understand what our role
is in this
conversation well I think our
our um Charter is
to ask for a performance
audit that look at how departments are
implementing the
will of the
legis and the legislature's will was go
do this program so it's certainly a
right to ask
for information on how the
Department's
asking how it's implementing it so can I
again this is a question of process not
necessarily a question of as I read this
again no you're correct normally under
the statute for our performance audit
committee we recommend audits to the
phisical committee who goes goes about
it that's the normal process we're
outside of the normal process because
now we have a statute that requires a
performance audit that isn't in here we
even if we want to say no we can't
because we have a law that says we're
compelled to do one um and so we can't
say no to the audit um the question is
what the audit contains and so we're
we're subject to 1131 uh 1135 Roman
numeral 2 it says the legislative budget
assistant shall submit audit scope
statement to the legislative performance
audit committee for review and approval
and submit the final report to the um to
the oversight committee and da we've
already done our part right we've
already reviewed the scope we've already
reviewed so now it just up to the
agencies to do it um what we've said and
I guess I'm trying to understand are we
talking about now revising the scope
after we've already approved it is that
the discussion because no we didn't do a
mad this came through by right San with
me Madam chair I to clarify I think what
we are doing right now we right we have
we scope is decided not by us the scope
is what it is but this is a very
important conversation because we're
hearing from the LBA that the department
of Ed is sort of blocking the
information that they need to conduct
the audit that's what we're discussing
right now and maybe we need to get the
LBA back up to sort of confirm that but
what I'm hearing is that we have a very
clear scope we're not arguing about
scope but LBA is saying that they cannot
get the information that they need to
complete it
without uh cooperation from the
Department of Ed and to be clear our
position is that we don't own nor do we
have access to that
data okay mad I go back to I go back
what's our role here um the scope's been
defined by Statute uh um the agencies
are going through it what vote could we
possibly take in this committee to
change anything in the outcome of this
conversation our role is public
discourse so the public needs to hear
about this I
mean um the contract clearly states that
the state owns the data I mean I I just
don't think there's
another way to read it because of that
or whether or not the department chooses
to ask for it it's a completely
different issue I don't know why you
wouldn't but so so respectfully we
disagree and we have sought legal
counsel as well as the Attorney
General's office and and information on
this
so okay representative
Weber I'm sorry following up on Senator
Lang's Point uh we have two different
things going here we have the audit as
it was mandated by Statute which has to
be completed in some
format and at that point this committee
or even before it is completed this
committee has the authority to ask for
different audits different parameters
different conditions so uh if if I think
that that is our our remedy if if we
want to do some changes I mean it sounds
to me like there's every opportunity
here to get a third branch of government
involved in deciding who has the
authority to say who can do which and
one would fervently hope that that is
not
necessary uh because I personally
speaking only for myself would fervently
hope that with a program of this size
and scope and
importance and
expense that the department would take
the pro the the position that
transparency is Paramount and when I say
that I am not asking for individuals tax
returns or anything else the audit
division audits all kinds of incredibly
personal sensitive information from all
kinds of sources all the time and they
have Professional Standards that require
them to keep anything that is
confidential confidential it's only what
they use in
evaluating whether the
statutory mandates put on an agency are
being followed
so that's just personal opinion and I'm
having let it out I'm going to leave it
there and hope that we hear from the
audit division because I think the
position of the Department of Education
is sufficiently clear whether I agree
with it or not but and so again we don't
believe we own the data we believe that
they can meet the obligations of the
statute auditing the department as it's
enumerated in
statute mad Madam chair before you get
to the LBA shouldn't we hear from the
AG's office the ag office the LBA back
first one question
yes one more question question so again
putting
dat when you're you're under that
10.2 you're more than willing that any
data that you've given to the to the
scholarship commission you're willing to
share with the with LBA that's your data
correct my data we 100% will be
providing all of that information as
requested thank
you um I'll just mention that I've seen
a bureau of elderly an adult Services
performance audit which also deals that
department deals with social security
numbers and income and very sensitive
personal health information and there's
never been a question
of um making any
individuals information public through
that audit so the LBA like to respond to
those
charges yes I I'll provide a response
but first my name is Michael Kain uh the
legislative budget assistant um just a
couple things that we don't take
anything as an attack personally I don't
I talk to my staff we do operat as an
office any uh decision that our Auditors
make I take personal responsibility for
if there is an disagreement with the
Department we reach out uh I have had
discussions with the attorney general's
office is to make sure that we're both
parties are on the same page um I do not
want to characterize uh doe as blocking
our access to any information I think
it's a very important question I think
Christopher Von's uh behind me but it's
it's a very important um what you were
talking about the provision of the
contract and information that's really
contractual law what is the uh what are
the rights of the in the the access of
the actual contractor but what does the
department have access to that is a
legal question we have to be very
careful with there in just to point out
we're not moving forward with anything
today we're providing you with an update
we do have to come back pursuant to that
chapter law to have you approve a scope
before we me move forward we're very
very early in the process this is a very
important conversation to have as we
move forward uh what information are we
able to access and I I think the
Attorney General can kind of clarify
that um and then after that we have to
work very closely with the department to
get that information as um our auditor
had stated the department of education
does have an oversite they do have a new
employee uh who is performing a lot of
the work who has been there for under a
year uh as you said Senator Rose Maul
there was an effective date but there's
no deadline there's no demand date when
this has to be done by when we have to
start I think there are a lot of things
that are still going on right now that
have to be clarified um I do just want
to point out to the department to the
commissioner and to his employees we
really do app appreciate the efforts
they've taken over the last two years we
have been there over two years on
various audits uh we're directed by you
as well as legisl we really appreciate
them working with us and providing the
information um it's a lot of information
that we ask the audit process is very
difficult it's very difficult for the
audit to perform their daily functions
on top of monitoring legislation court
cases and everything and we respect that
um so we do appreciate everything that
they're provided to date uh we hope
going forward that we can continue to
work on this audit and comply with the
statute as we are required I would have
if with Christopher bonds here uh just
have him to come up to kind of go over
um kind of just the details in the uh
the contract relative to property and
who owns it and I don't know if you
wanted to comment good great thank you
Mr
Rond
I'm in trouble when I'm Christopher and
not Chris
so uh Chris Bond associate attorney
general uh so unlike the last time I was
up here with the Secretary of State
think it's certainly not our position
that this isn't un
auditable thing um and I certainly
understand a lot of The Angst and
frustration about uh
not getting materials that folks think
are necessary to audit the program the I
think part of the
difficulty and I think it's been touched
on by attorney Brown and by commissioner
ad BL um is uh the way one 94f is
structured that the scholarship
organization is a specific identified
entity in the statute that has its own
specific responsibility so it is a lot
different I know early parts of this
discussion when I was listening people
were talking about you know a vendor of
the department it's lots of times
agencies will have a function and to
perform that function they will they
will do an RFP and they will get an
outside entity in this instance it was
mandated that they do it that way and
the statute has specific functions for
that specific um uh vendor I mean they
did do an RFP process and and pick the
vendor that in that me with that
mechanism but that is a uh statutorily
defined entity that has statutory duties
in and of itself separate from the
department but the the uh the session
law that created this audit is
specifically auditing the department so
um I think that is what's causing a lot
of the the uh The Angst is that the
Department's role in the administering
of this program is is actually quite
limited and more limited than you might
imagine so I know you've got a copy of
194f and I'd encourage you to take a
look at it and I think that might be
creating some of the friction here but
in terms of this uh this this uh
contractual issue I think um leaving
aside for a moment the merits of whether
or not the data we're talking about
falls under 10.2 or not I think the
issue that we ident ify at the AG's
office
is the the scholarship organization has
contractual privity with the agency not
with the LBA so if the LBA Auditors have
a different interpretation of the
statute than the uh department and they
think the Department's wrong that's a
certainly a valid audit finding to do
but the the the uh the thing that we uh
find potentially problematic is for the
Auditors to sort of stand in the shoes
of the department and exercise rights
the department has under their contract
with a third party so that and that's
sort of where um when the department
reached out to us early on and said
they're you know they're asking us to
collect to get data that we don't have
that we don't think we have access to um
you we we responded that yeah it would
not be appropriate for you to it's not
appropriate for the Auditors to be
exercising Authority that the agency has
but but it's certainly appropriate for
the Auditors to identify
that the agency is not exercising
Authority that they think they have
contractually if that was part of their
oversight obligation so I don't I don't
know if I'm being clear but I I my my
point is just that um it's this dispute
about what the contract allows access to
is certainly an auditable thing and the
Auditors and the department may end up
disagreeing and that may well end up
being what the uh audit ends up being
fundamentally about but um where the LBA
doesn't agree with the a agency they
don't have the ability to stand in the
shoes of the agency and gain contractual
privity with the third party in this
case the scholarship organization
so you know the more I look at 10.2 the
more ungrammatical it is and there's a
missing comma there is a missing comma
after property yep right and I and I
feel compelled to point out uh that this
language is from the state's p 37 so
this is essentially in every single
contract that we have with every vendor
so it's ungrammatical but if you imagine
that comma placed where it should
be the all
data is the property of the state
because it's been bought with State
funds whether the
department
exercises its authority to get that
information I think is yeah I mean I
think discussable yeah the difficulty
for me is I don't know exactly what
information has been requested but I I
certainly I think I heard the
commissioner say in response to Senator
Lang's question that there is some data
the scholarship organization has that
the commissioner understands does fall
under this because any information that
any data that the
department gave it so any information
that the scholarship organization
received from the state um that would be
information that they could get back I
think the push back is on certain data
that's collected directly from
recipients that is neither provided by
the state nor purchased with funds
provided under this agreement so I I
think that's where the friction is but
I'm not exactly familiar with the scope
of the data that the obba is looking for
but I'm just thinking more fundamentally
and going back to sort of process if the
LBA and the agency don't agree on what
that contractual provision says and and
maybe the LBA thinks it's perfectly
clear it means this other thing that's a
valid audit finding but it's not it's
it's not a mechanism to compel the
agency to take any specific action even
if the even if it's action that
theoretically the agency should be
taking it's not the lb's purview to
compel that action got it re
Weber so that's a perfect lead into my
question which is if the LBA cannot
compel
that
um I'm assuming without knowing it is
our
duty to figure out how to compel that
and my question you as an Assistant
Attorney General is how if this
committee desires that information and
believes that and this is all
hypothetical
if this committee believed that the
department Ed of Education was incorrect
in their
interpretation what would the remedy be
how would we fix that problem well
that's a great question and I'm
certainly understand why you want to
know that I'm not prepared to answer
that today I haven't looked into your
authorities to compel that kind of
information I do think if there were a
legitimate dispute um contractural
dispute um was it you who mentioned the
third party the third branch of
government needing to step in at some
point I mean hopefully we don't get to
that point but I mean that's a
possibility I mean generally that's
Courts are there to resolve contract
disputes but it would be an interesting
frame here especially if the scholarship
organization and the agency had the same
interpretation and it was a essentially
a third party with a different
understanding
um but uh and also because this is part
of our standard um language that is in
basically all state contracts and less
modified
um there may be some case law on this
too there may be um but again it would
depend on the specific data which I'm
not I have not looked at what what the
specific um requests are for information
to know but I do know that we have in
the past interpreted this as um being
limited to data provided by the a agency
or purchased with funds and uh and
vendors push back on that a lot ask for
clarification a lot because they're very
concerned they often bring expertise and
knowledge and intellectual property to
the table and they want to make sure
that this isn't read so broadly that it
Scoops all that stuff up so thank
you yes L again the way I read it is
it's a state if if they use State funds
to buy a study the study trending in you
know early childhood education missed
the first part of that so if if if the
scholarship Association had used State
funds to buy a study about education in
some form that would be discoverable and
available for this purpose right yes
because that's direct but a child
applying for the program wouldn't be
funds wouldn't be funded wouldn't be
something that was bought by the by
State dollars right and it wouldn't be
data or property received from the state
I so that would be outside the scope of
the contract yeah but but again even if
even if it were say there was this study
uh this hypothetical study that the
scholarship organization paid for I
agree in that scenario the department
would be able to get that information
from the scholarship organization but if
the department told the LBA Auditors we
can't get that information I still don't
think it would be correct for the
Auditors to reach out to the scholarship
organization to get it I think that
would be the basis of an audit finding
saying the department is not doing their
job here they have this clear
contractual right to get this
information that they should be getting
to oversee the program and they're not
doing it that's the way I Envision that
playing out right but the demographic
data that we talked about right a child
applying for is not purchase data it's
not so therefore it's outside the scope
of the definition of data and from the
state thank you representative Weber oh
sorry I it's
first I'm just again
bewildered by the assertion that the
state has not purchased this property
because the state's funding the entire
program
so all funding for everything is coming
from the
state um but again that is something
that I assume that the LBA is going to
discuss in their findings and and can go
on from there I just want to make make
it known that you know it's not like
this is an organization of the kind you
were discussing where they bring
intellectual property or a a specific
type of of uh data management or
anything else to the table this is all
data that is purchased with State
funds because it's the state that's
funding the entire
program so we're going to go Senator
Lang then we're going to go
representative Earth and then we're
going to go Pearl and Whitley
right I have the same interpretation as
the Attorney General I I believe
hope we
do might I make my motion
now um no more more questions more hands
up Senator Pearl thank you so I guess my
question is and I'm trying to understand
State money portion is the fulfilling a
or awarding a grant considered
purchasing information with State money
or purchasing something with State money
I mean that that wouldn't be my
understanding I mean if if we took that
interpretation that anytime there was a
grant anything an agen an eny did would
would uh it would it would pull a lot of
things in that I don't think that the
word purchase implies if we were to do
it that broadly follow well that that's
kind of what I'm thinking
so I guess I'm trying to draw the line
as to what we're purchasing with State
money and where we're awarding a grant I
guess that's kind of where I'm trying to
because the
the education Freedom counts are are a
grant that we provide these students so
what what does the state entitled to own
of that information for that
student under under this contract or
under the program I I guess either or
I'm trying to get a handle on exactly so
I do think I mean I do think there's a
distinction here I mean we're focused
here on a a particular section of the
p37 and what it means so we're talking
about the rights contractual rights
between an agency and a third party that
they've contracted with here but then
there's also the program so that as I
said the uh RSA
194f ascribes specific statutory
functions to the scholarship
organization so there certainly may be a
vehicle there for this body to get at
that information but not through a
chapter law that's advising or that that
is uh asking for an audit of the
Department of Education where the only
mechanism is this is this contractual
provision um so I I it's not it's not
not as if 10.2 means the state could
never look at this there may be a way
and I agnostic on that because I haven't
looked into it but looking at the
structure of 194 there may be other
avenues here including a direct audit of
the scholarship organization potentially
um but this isn't that and so but I
think with here um you know the fact
that they're administering the program I
mean the the information that I
understand to be at issue but I'm not
100% sure because I haven't seen the
actual data requests uh or info or
document requests but the
information that is subject would be
information that is provided by
individuals to the scholarship
organization not not paid for by the
scholarship organization which is what a
purchase would imply so if I may just
kind of finish the train of thought here
so essentially if I'm understanding you
then that the information that the
Scholarship Foundation or schol
children's scholarship fund has on
individual app applicants because
they're receiving a grant would not
necessarily be subject to considered
property of the state not not under 10.2
purchase language but possibly
statutorily in a different mechanism
possibly yeah thank you just trying to
make sure I got my head Senator Whitley
thank you madam chair I I just want to
reorient to the committee and also you
know to you that we're talking about $24
million of taxpayer dollars that's
potentially going to be even more if the
governor signs a bill increasing the
income eligibility that is a lot of
money and a very resource scarce State
and so this interpretation is troubling
as you can understand because we do have
an obligation to make sure that taxpayer
dollars are being spent appropriately
and so what I'm hearing from the LBA and
also from your interpretation is that
we're not able to determine whether
these dollars are being spent
appropriately whether $24 million ofx
taxpayer dollars is being spent
appropriately we're not able to do that
that's what I'm
hearing not through the mechanism of a
performance audit of the Department of
education's administering of the program
but possibly through another
mechanism thank
you I just would point so be clear the
answer yes we can but this is wrong the
way we're going about it it's not
proper I
yes maybe I haven't looked into it but I
expect yes maybe the answer is always it
depends but yes my not not through this
mechanism right so the $24 million is
this year yep last year was 18 and the
first year was I don't know eight or
nine again my my point to maybe this
answer Senator Lang it's not the doj is
saying we can't figure out if
These funds are
being spent as the legislature intended
them I don't think the program is UN
auditable I don't but we don't think
this chapter law gets to the scholarship
organization through the vehicle of this
um vendor contract thank you thank you
all right thanks okay I don't think we
need a motion though because it's a
statutory audited and the statutorily
required so is it clear this point that
clear to you at this point that the Ed
Department of education's perspective is
the one that will be followed and that
there'll be no need to press out to the
children's scholarship fund I I think
it's clear that the
legislation requires an audit of the
department not of the
contractor that part's clear to me okay
I mean I agree with that if that's where
we are
y i I just I don't think there's any so
again I think and and to Mike's point I
was going to speak to next is that at
this point we're still developing a
scope that has to come back to us by the
number two understanding what that scope
is now with the understanding of all the
conversation we just have with the AG
and a everything else so we're still
going to hear about this again when they
bring It Forward um for a vote so we
still got to get a scope of work within
the confines that we just discussed
absolutely and I just want to thank uh
Chris Bond uh for that clarification Mr
Bond Mr Bond Chris Bond
uh so um if it's very early on if
there's a disagreement this is not an
audit finding by any means we're not
even in there with the scope or anything
we have conversations with agencies that
we may disagree at first but then
hearing from an attorney uh we we may
change our mind and it's very clear we
like to get that so it's very very early
we're not I just wanted to clarify we're
not putting an observation out today
we're not even in there we're just
gathering information we're learning
ourselves um and so I just I appreciate
this conversation for my behalf and our
Auditor's behalf to just understand
everything that goes into this so thank
you but we have just discussed it for an
hour and a the next step is that they'll
bring it on some they'll bring some time
forward and we'll be talking about it
again looking forward to
it wait okay but we're not done no
so more there's more suspended tabled
and potential audit
topics and i' note that I think you all
got an email from representative
Lynn suggesting an audit
topic oh well Jay did you bring copies
up I have
it yeah I have it
because
okay
okay address the well
um yes if everyone has seen
it okay yes margorie come on
up no same subject Environmental
Services dispute resolution
soltion aren't you glad you're not on
this
committee actually I'm sad that I'm not
on this committee um um Madam chair you
can take the girl out of Finance but you
can't take Finance out of the girl and I
love this committee and it is I believe
one of the most important committees
that we have have in the legislature
although it is unknown to many
people um several almost two years ago
now the Judiciary Committee asked you to
consider um uh a per a performance order
for the human relations uh commission
and we're waiting patiently for the
results um this time um we came we're
coming to you because because we had a
bill that came to us um and the prime
sponsor of the bill had to
leave understandably not expecting to
take the whole day here um it concerns
the department of um invironmental
Services each of the Departments we know
as the way we have the government
structured are are large they're very
complex they have lots of subdivisions
lots of barriers of
responsibility and um it makes it very
complicated to run those
departments uh the Department of
Environmental Services has
four different units that handle
hearings and appeals and the rules of
each one of those units differs one from
the
other uh and uh which makes it a very
very complex problem to be able um to
administer um representative MC willians
came to us um because of a concern about
what was happening with uh
um situations relating to housing we
know how important housing is we don't
have enough
housing um and she had a number of
concerns S one of them was that in at
least one of those four separate
lines um there would could be a an a a
complaint filed a decision reached and
then if you want to appeal the decision
you have to go to the very same people
who made the
decision and that seemed to be a
little strange it didn't make sense and
as we've looked further into the
legislation um we realized that how the
department was trying to coordinate each
of these disperate oh dear did I offend
the
chair
oh oh okay um sorry uh was was made no
sense if it's okay with you madam chair
I would like to ask one of my colleagues
representative man
who worked very closely on the
underlying Bill to come and join me and
talk about why we think the
existing procedure doesn't make any
sense the bill would have put in place
yet an entirely different level that
would have um created the opportunity
for a denovo hearing you know beginning
at the beginning again none of that made
sense and we concluded
that the department might benefit from
some
help that would come from a performance
audit so that they could better do what
we asked them to do and is
representative representative Manos is
right here and so is representative MC
Williams oh oh I'm sorry I I saw you
leave but I didn't see you come back yes
so if I could ask the two of them to
come up would would that be acceptable
it would be if the committee is willing
to stay thank you very
much it seems like the house you're
supposed to have left
[Music]
apparently Finance Finance at just our
turn okay you know what is we waited our
turn thank you
welcome thank you uh I'm representative
Manos from stratum um uh representative
MC Williams did draft this bill um and
sponsored it it was heard by the
Judiciary Committee uh I think one of
the major points is that there are four
separate councils to which you can
appeal a Dees decision they're the air
Resources Council the wetlands Council
the water Council and the waste
management Council and they hear uh
appeals and they review administrative
rules during the testimony on the bill
we heard from the supervisor I believe
it was of one of the councils I believe
it was Wetland Wetlands Council and we
learned during the course of the hearing
that they each of these councils has
different standards for their appeals
they have different rules and so you can
get an inconsistent outcome on an issue
depending on which Council you're in
front of um in addition to that once
there's a hearing your appeal right is
to to the Supreme Court and there's no
process part of the problem is
introducing new scientific evidence and
so there's um no opportunity for that to
occur but I think the main point here is
that you can have different outcomes
depending on the topic and the subject
matter and so um we are seeking the
performance audit to look at those
systemic issues um and how this can be
better handled the outcome on the
committee was a recommendation for
interim study and so we the committee as
a whole will it hasn't gone to the floor
yet but that may be the potential
outcome on the floor um but we're
interested in getting the review of the
broader
issues so I guess I have a question for
representative
Smith Bob Lynn's letter says all the
division s of Dees but the discussion
has been about the
four hearings and Appeals Council
so are you looking
for a performance audit on these four
different councils or
on all of the divisions with Dees which
I'm guessing are more than
four if I
could the problem that came to
us seemed to indicate that each that
what we thought at first was one area
was quickly multiplied really by
Department itself saying bringing to our
attention that it wasn't just one it was
all that I know because of my the high
regard which I hold
LBA that if you were to agree to let
them you know begin to look at this they
would and I know from P experience and
you know that they would say the best
way to do this would be to look at one
or look at across the board or however
and what our concern was to help the
department do the best possible job in
their hearing and appeal process and I
would leave it although I noticed that
the head of LBA isn't looking at me he's
groaning at the thought
that but we were hoping that you know
that from their perspective they could
say this is how to narrow this looks so
that it makes the most and I don't know
represent
uh thank you for the question and thank
you for the commentary uh I think that
we want to keep it broad for now and
possibly narrowed during the
investigation um I think that there's a
lot that could come out just from the
initial conversation uh with the inner
workings of how this is managed across
the four different departments and and
certainly inconsistency is not the goal
I think fairness is the goal and of
course Justice having brought this to
Judiciary is also the
goal thank you uh representative
could you just give me the name of the
four councils again please oh sure air
resources Wetlands water and waste very
slowly because I am old and have
arthritic fingers my apologies represent
I've got air air water the whole name
air Resources
Council
yep water
Council yep Wetlands Council
yep Waste Management Council thank you
very much
councils okay thank you
sure uh what do the committee you want
to
do
Senator I think it might be best to take
this up at our next meeting when we have
our full compliment again so that we can
have all of the members be able to weigh
in okay and I was going to ask following
up on that that um I understand the
initial desire for a broad look but um
broad looks take many times many
Auditors and are very expensive
so anything that members of the
Judiciary Committee could do between now
and our next meeting to help us really
closely
articulate what it is we're looking at
because um I I understand that the
overall Drive is fundamental fairness
and the conflicts between the the four
councils uh but not knowing how they're
interwork myself very well it would be
really helpful if you can do anything to
pinpoint more clearly the areas that we
need to look at so that we can start
with um a
beginning directive that will then
evolve into a scope statement going
forward so um thank you if I could add
just one thing the initial
concern was that's okay the initial
concern uh had to do with
housing um and it was from that area
that we then realized the problem was
much greater so the question is do you
look at the greater issue or do you look
at you know do you look at the whole
body or do you look at the toe and and
that that's the concern and that's why
the letter was worded the way it was mad
Madam chair but um and I also want to
make clear that uh representative MC
Williams is not on Judiciary she brought
the bill to us and it was uh you know
the Judiciary Committee that that then
went on from from there um but so that's
that's my concern thank thank you
Senator so my topics to Mike
um so we we just closed out at least two
audits with the third one be done in the
next three to four weeks and my question
is do we need to add anything to your
list so your people can continue to work
thank you for the question uh Christine
and Jay will be able to provide that to
you because they have some ideas I think
they are looking for topics because we
do not have the Secretary of State out
it anymore I think the EFA is going to
move you know we have a lot of work to
do before we start so if Jay Henry could
come up and just
uh talk to you about that 10
thank you one other thing is you know I
realize the four councils have different
appeals processes but there may be a
reason for that perhaps it would be good
to hear either from the commissioner of
De or perhaps director whims they could
speak to maybe why there's four
different appeals processes that might
clear some of the concern prior to a
good idea prior to putting together a
well I I just talked to Steve Grady our
in charge who did the wetlands audit uh
back a few years ago and part of that
was the wetlands Council and so there
was I think there was about a chapter
that talked about the W Wetlands Council
but he told me they didn't really get
involved in the hearings process however
he did mention that the reason why
there's each Council has a like
different rules or procedures they were
separated they were glued together at
one point to become the department
enironmental services so that's probably
the reason why each Council does it
their own way sure I just thought that
might be a valuable piece of information
to help if we're going to put a scope
together to perhaps understand let's
invite Commissioners gone to the N
meeting the only other thing I when I
was listening you know where Auditors
were doing how well did the program run
efficiency
Effectiveness um policy meaning
changing how you're going to organize
all these these these councils that may
maybe beyond what our traditional scope
is so what you know deciding what are
what we should look at which may help
you with policy but I don't know if it's
our duty to say here's the best way for
these councils to operate I mean we may
be able to look at other states and you
know you know give you some information
but you know we try not to go over that
line of suggesting policy to the
legislature well I'm still interested in
a performance audit of the door way
program because it's a we keep hearing
that overdoses are going up I think
they're and deaths in most places deaths
are going
down not necessarily in Manchester or
Nashua but would be good to um I think
know how quickly and
efficiently people are
hooked up with Treatment Services
because the the purpose of
this a Statewide program is to get
people quickly
connected with Treatment
Services can people afford it how long
is the wait how many calls go to the
nighttime and weekend call center rather
than the Monday through Friday daytime
operation so I think that's still worth
looking at as well and that program's
been operating for at least five years
we haven't looked at
it hold again I want first we got to
find out how much work they need so we
have an idea of what we're going to vote
on and what might be because for me I
have a different priority and that's the
DHHS and children's Behavioral Health
right so but first let's find out what
they have room
for okay thank you so there's a long
list of audit topics here that are
suspended and we're hoping to tidy up
this list a little bit and sort of
prioritize so we'd like to hear from the
committee on each one of these if
possible uh the first one was Bureau of
elderly and Adult Services this topic
was suspended more than two years ago um
in November of 2021 due to a legal
proceeding uh we haven't received an
update on this so just wondering if
there's further discussion on this do we
want to keep this topic on the list or
remove it um has that litigation
resolved no I don't think so
so okay
okay forward at the moment okay next is
the um public access to bodies of water
that was tabled as it was noted there
might be another committee responsible
uh for this
topic do we have any further discussion
do we want to keep it on the list or
remove
it my guess is we should probably we
should probably knowing that we want to
either remove things or not we probably
got to do a little research so I'm not
sure going to get any votes to remove
anything from the list today okay um but
knowing that you do want to remove
things we can start looking at them and
see which items and where they stand and
and look to the next meeting as to
making a a recommendation for what items
we want to ultimately remove off the
list to at least that would be my
recommendation to the
chair may I comment yes sen well some of
us are somewhat new to this committee
having only been on a little over a year
I I really don't know the history on
many of these things and it's difficult
for me to say yeah remove it or yes keep
it on is there possibility that you
could at least give us uh some typee of
a briefing as to what each one you know
like a simple paragraph that would say
like the office of the oplc one it was
tabled but what what in general was it
trying to look at because it's real hard
to know whether I want to remove it or
not sure I'm also new to the committee
but yes we can certainly provide a
little update on that and give you a
summary of what the topics were I think
they'd be very beneficial to many of us
trying to decide whether we want to keep
these or removed okay absolutely y I
don't expect we're going to make any
decisions okay right but if you could
tell us how much space you have so next
meeting if you want to move something
forward we have an idea of how much work
you want sure so we have one um
performance audit manager that will be
freeing up probably in April so we are
looking for one topic uh now that the
archives audit is off the list we will
definitely need at least one topic very
soon Madam chair for my purposes again
having that recent case with the child
with having been stuck in the Ed room
for ages he he's all set now but but
when the wind stop yeah so the so my my
my uh and thank you for your help on
that case to get that child taken care
of but I'm interested in interplay
between DHHS and the and the behavioral
health and mental health services
component moving that forward as a big
topic for me to uh it's not an area I've
usually focused on but now that I've had
my eyes open to it I'm I'm really
interested in how the state's managing
this process and how we're getting our
children especially the mental health
services children the services they need
as fast as possible um and so for me
that would be a topic that I'd be really
interested moving forward next next
meeting if if everybody agrees but this
is about the interplay between well I
think that was part of the problem we
had a little bit yeah to want to revise
that topic well again that's where I
think having a little one
paragraph right because that was not
ad right so anyway yeah um
great okay so sounds like we need a new
another meeting quite quickly yeah yeah
uh we need a
meeting certainly by early April
what April Fool's Day wouldn't that
be
I I could do
that I am
available 15th is going to be tougher
for me I'm available is Commission on
Aging I I made an exception for today
but I'd like not to miss it twice when
is that uh that's the 15th
okay I could do I could do the eth the
eth is the eclipse folks I don't want to
mess up that for the morning of the eth
but not the
afternoon anybody needing to get up to
the North Country may be upset about
that what was the problem with the first
96% coverage right here in concerete
does the eth work in the morning are you
talking about April 8th it certainly
works for me I don't have S you're
talking about April 8 yeah morning yeah
before 10 well I know we have meetings
but Howard I'm fine with it but I I
think representative Weber may be making
a point that maybe some folks to take
the day off to go to see the eclipse and
I don't know if that affects who we have
available okay 2
second that was all I was thinking I'm
personally not going before
one I could
do education yeah yeah I can't I can't
do any Tuesday or Wednesdays Monday's
the best day Monday's the best what was
what was wrong with a April
1 you're fooling right nothing no why
don't we just do it April 1 and get it
over
with I'm not available that please don't
work around everyone
else I mean first is good for me same
I'm really
sorry was but I think you know we have a
birthday and an unavailability so maybe
happy birthday to Senator General on
first but what was the problem with the
22nd of 2 next week no the 22nd of April
looking for early April so we can get
them because we took right we need to
give them Madam chair yes I just wanted
to let you know that we we could
possibly put off receiving a topic for
like a for a month 30 days so it's not
we don't need it in two weeks so I just
want to let you know that in case you so
if we met on the 22nd would that be okay
of April or the 15th the 15th was
commissioned on Aging for me and
somebody else had a problem with it too
I can only meet in the afternoon on the
22nd all right we're back to April 1
let's look at that
okay April 1 is fine of the me April 1
is fine with me although I have to be in
da at
threee let's not go till three
no if I could also mention the other
consideration is we were thinking at the
next meeting we could possibly have the
scope statement for the education
Freedom account program now that we
received clarification today about about
the uh scope of the audit but if we do
schedule the meeting for April 1st we
might be a little short on time for
having the scope statement at that
meeting so I'll just give you that
information and let you decide what
about the 29th what about April
2 I'm good for the 29th 29th is good for
me um the
29th works all right okay we have a plan
in the morning yep 10 nine n
nine be here at nine you guys don't have
to travel as far yeah no we're not going
to meet at 9 because poor Senator jenra
that's I can we could meet at
9:30 9 9 is fine really yeah nine is
fine
okay
need it's 9 o' Nine's fine for me I've
been doing it for a long time
the
29th the 29th at 9:00 a.m. my Cane's
going to have to get up
early all right with that I think we can
Jour thank you all very much thank you
madam thank you madam chair thank you
all
for